la inmunización es el proceso de hacerse
inmune a una enfermedad o de protegerse
contra ella Generalmente mediante la
aplicación de una vacuna
las vacunas estimulan el sistema
inmunitario con el fin de protegerlo de
ciertas enfermedades para que no se
enferme ni contraiga una infección
por lo general los órganos y las células
del sistema inmunitario defienden al
organismo de gérmenes nocivos como las
bacterias y los virus
las células inmunitarias circulan de
manera constante por el cuerpo vigilan
ciertas sustancias en la superficie de
las células llamadas antígenos
las células sanas tienen antígenos
diferentes de los de las células
enfermas o de Los Invasores extraños en
el cuerpo
las células inmunitarias suelen ignorar
los antígenos de las células sanas pero
cuando las células inmunitarias se
encuentran antígenos en los gérmenes
destruyen el germen después la célula
inmunitaria fija el antígeno del germen
en su superficie
esto activa otros tipos de células
inmunitarias para ayudar a deshacerse de
la infección
[Música]
por ejemplo algunas células inmunitarias
activadas reconocen el antígeno de las
células infectadas del organismo y luego
las destruyen
otras células inmunitarias activadas
llamadas células plasmáticas producen
moléculas llamadas anticuerpos
estos anticuerpos viajan a través del
organismo y se fijan solo a los gérmenes
que tienen su antígeno específico esto
marca el germen de la destrucción
[Música]
luego otras células inmunes atacan a los
gérmenes que tienen estos anticuerpos
una vez que la infección desaparece
algunas de las células inmunes que
fueron expuestas al antígeno se
convierten en células inmunitarias de
memoria en el futuro si el mismo tipo de
germen vuelve a infectar su organismo
las células inmunitarias de memoria
estarán listas para destruirlo para que
no se enferme esto se llama inmunidad
natural en muchos casos durará toda la
vida
el problema de obtener una inmunidad
natural por tener la enfermedad en sí
misma es que algunas infecciones
adquiridas naturalmente pueden causar
complicaciones graves o incluso pueden
ser mortales por ejemplo la
poliomielitis puede provocar una
parálisis permanente o la muerte
el sarampión puede causar una
inflamación en el cerebro lo que provoca
un daño cerebral permanente o la muerte
especialmente en los niños menores de 5
años y la tosferina también conocida
como tos convulsa puede causar
complicaciones como la neumonía
detención de la respiración o
respiración lenta y la muerte
especialmente en los bebés menores de un
año
aunque los síntomas pueden no ser graves
en todas las personas no es posible
saber quiénes se verán lo
suficientemente afectados como para
enfermarse gravemente o incluso morir
las vacunas pueden protegerlo de
contraer estas enfermedades y de sus
síntomas nocivos las vacunas suelen
contener una pequeña cantidad de
gérmenes debilitados o muertos sin
embargo algunas contienen material
genético como ARN o ADN que proporcionan
instrucciones para que las propias
células del organismo produzcan el
antígeno del germen por lo general se
recibe una vacuna en forma de inyección
dentro de su organismo las partículas de
los gérmenes de la vacuna enseñan a las
células inmunitarias a atacar estos
gérmenes este proceso no lo enferma pero
sí hace que su organismo produzca
células de memoria y anticuerpos para
esos gérmenes
En consecuencia si ese germen infecta su
organismo más adelante en su vida su
sistema inmunitario Estará listo para
combatir la infección para que no se
enferme
los principales tipos de vacunas
incluyen vacunas vivas y atenuadas
vacunas inactivas
vacunas toxoides
vacunas de subnidades y conjugadas
vacunas de arnm y vacunas de vectores
virales
las vacunas vivas atenuadas usan
gérmenes vivos pero debilitados son como
una infección natural y proporcionan una
fuerte inmunidad a la enfermedad
ejemplos son las vacunas en aerosol
nasal contra el sarampión las paperas la
rubéola la varicela y la gripe las
vacunas inactivas utilizan gérmenes
inactivos o muertos
es posible que con el tiempo necesite
varias dosis o inyecciones de refuerzo
ejemplos de ellos son las vacunas contra
la hepatitis a la gripe la poliomielitis
y la rabia
las vacunas toxoides protegen contra las
sustancias nocivas producidas por los
gérmenes llamadas toxinas
utilizan versiones debilitadas de las
toxinas llamadas toxoides
es posible que necesite inyecciones de
refuerzo para mantener la protección
contra las enfermedades ejemplos de
ellos son las partes de difteria y
tétanos de la vacuna de teap
las vacunas suponitarias y conjugadas
utilizan sólo una parte específica de un
germen proporcionan una fuerte inmunidad
a esa parte esencial del germen estas
vacunas también pueden requerir
inyecciones de refuerzo ejemplos de
ellos son la parte de la vacuna contra
la tosferina de la dpap y la vacuna
contra la hepatitis b
en lugar de utilizar gérmenes o toxinas
las vacunas de arnm contienen un tipo
especial de ARN llamado ARN mensajero o
arnmm el arnm ordena las células que
produzcan el antígeno del germen lo que
desencadena una respuesta inmunitaria
estas vacunas no llevan virus vivos y no
cambian el ADN algunos ejemplos son las
vacunas para la Kobe 19 las vacunas con
vectores virales pueden utilizar el ADN
o el arnm para proporcionar a las
células las instrucciones para producir
el antígeno de un germen el material
genético está envuelto en un virus
diferente y seguro para llevar las
instrucciones a las células estas
vacunas no cambian el ADN algunos
ejemplos son las vacunas para la covid
Es importante saber que las vacunas no
Solo lo protegen a usted sino también a
su comunidad
muchas de las enfermedades que las
vacunas previenen se transmiten de
persona a persona cuando solo se vacunan
unas pocas personas de su comunidad el
riesgo de un brote de enfermedad es alto
pero si la mayoría de las personas están
vacunadas es mucho menos probable que
una enfermedad se propague esto se llama
inmunidad comunitaria o de rebaño la
inmunidad de rebaño es especialmente
importante para proteger a las personas
que no pueden ser vacunadas esto incluye
a las personas con sistemas inmunitarios
debilitados alergias graves u otras
enfermedades las vacunas lo protegen a
usted a su familia y a su comunidad de
enfermedades que pueden ser peligrosas o
incluso mortales
para obtener más información sobre las
vacunas hable con su proveedor de
atención médica